my first week in the building about a
year ago
i went down to the courtyard for the
first time and
i didn't look too good you know it was a
sunday morning
that's my least presentable hour
there's a lot of you know just stains
just like you know food
and me and whatever and someone said
i'm sitting there
so shut up
oh anyway but so there i was
i'm sitting on the stone bench of this
courtyard and
uh feeling a little out of place you
know there's these fancy doormen and
stuff and then there's this guy looking
at me i notice he's looking at me from
across the
courtyard and he's all spiffy looking
he's got brown shoes and he's looking at
me like hmm i could tell
he was thinking i don't live in the
building he thinks i just wandered in
off the streets
and sat in a courtyard i can tell he's
thinking of coming over and dealing with
me on his own
and i'm sitting there thinking like oh
please do that yes
please come on come on come on come on
and i'm trying to look even more gross
and i'm like pulling up my
shirt and then i see him go oh no
that's not gonna do at all and he comes
over to me
and i'm like i'm so excited to have this
thing
the confrontation where i'm not wrong at
all
and he thinks i am so
he comes over says uh excuse me do you
live in this building and i said no
because why not start there
i said no he goes well then what are you
doing here
and i said i just need to rest i'm
having a hard time
he says this is private property and i
said well i don't really believe in that
you know just the worst things i could
say from his point of view
is basically all the things i was saying
and he goes well if you don't leave i'm
going to talk to the doorman i was like
can i just stay like five more hours
so he's noon
he goes over to the doorman and i see
him talking about me to the doorman like
this
and then i see the doorman going oh no
that guy lives here it's okay
and the look on his face it was just so
it was this beautiful cocktail
of anger and confusion
it's like i hadn't invented a new way to
hurt somebody's feelings that's
that's how excited i was
he was so angry he came back came back
to me
said why didn't you tell me that you
live here
and i said cause i don't have to tell
you anything ever
there are no words that i must say to
you
also i didn't want to ruin your thing
that's your favorite thing you were
doing
you love that making people not be
places
also i make more than you i just don't
give a [ __ ] about myself
anyway he didn't say anything after that
because uh well the whole thing didn't
really
happen
i mean well
it's it's not true but it's as it's as
true as anything that does happen
i mean really
anytime anybody says anything to me i
decide what they said
anyway
the truth of this story and i won't lie
to you again but here's what really
happened
i was sitting in the courtyard looking
like [ __ ] that's true
and the guy was looking at me but then
the rest of it i just
made up in my head just this is an angry
hateful
rich dick you probably want to kick me
out and then here's what i would say and
then
you would do this i would say these
three really cool things right in a row
and of course he set me up for all of
them because i'm him too it's kind of
hard to
lose an argument when you're both people
and it's taking place in your brain
and then in reality he really did come
up to me and he said are you new to the
building and i said yeah i just moved
here and he said oh welcome he was
so nice he was incredibly nice
and he's been for the last years my
favorite person in the world he's george
my neighbor george
he's probably watching i love george
he's the greatest
some woman right who um
the sort of bedroom is on par to our
kitchen right
yeah so i'm sort of washing up yeah and
i sort of look across
and see see this woman with uh
like you know no no pants on that no no
bra
naked yeah just that's the word you're
looking for yeah yeah she's just
wondering about we're now on that
so i was like oh what's going on so i
carried on washing up on that right
and uh kept looking and then i was
looking and she looked at me
right so we made eye contact sure so i
was like oh god
all right so um what i thought the best
thing to do was
was sort of drop me pants a little bit
just just a little bit just like you
know i had boxer shorts on and i thought
if i just show a little bit of
a little bit of sort of ass cheek then
it's kind of like right we quits
don't understand the thinking
so suzanne's watching the telly right i
think she's watching sex in the city or
something yeah
she sort of turns around to see how i'm
getting on with the washing up right
she sees me with like me pants sort of
down a little bit let me ass out
she said what you doing i said don't
look now i said but there's a woman
over the road all right we know pants on
that she caught me looking
i'm just giving her a bit back
i love the fact that he explains the
rules and suicide's about to go
okay that makes sense but i don't so so
hang on so you you you showed a bit of
your ass you turned presumably to show
the i saw why
i had to lift it up a little bit on the
sort of on the draining board what hang
on though
um what did she do did you register her
reaction when she saw a bit of your ass
what happened
when she saw my ass yeah well then i
wasn't looking because i thought
in a way i don't want i don't want it to
look like
well i've seen a bit of your stuff is a
bit of mine i just thought at the end of
the day i caught a glance for you
it's only fair you've had a bit back you
know
i genuinely think james stewart missed a
trick here in real window yeah
this would have been you know a much
better film uh james stewart
just popped his pants down it would have
given a whole new meaning to the to the
title rear window
yeah exactly all right everybody
this would be fun i used to live here in
los angeles on sierra bonita
and i had an apartment and i had a
neighbor and whenever he would knock on
my wall
i knew he wanted me to turn my music
down and that made me angry because i
liked loud music
so when he knocked on the wall i'd mess
with his head
i'd say go around
i cannot open the wall
i don't know if you have a doorknob on
the other side
but over here there's nothing
it's just flag
i'll give you an example how race
affects my life okay
i live in a place called alpine
new jersey live in alpine new jersey
right my house costs
millions of dollars
don't hate the player hate the game
in my neighborhood there are four black
people
hundreds of houses four black people who
are these black people well it's me
mary j blige jay-z
and eddie murphy only black people in
the whole neighborhood
so let's break it down let's break it
down me i'm a decent comedian am i right
uh mary j blige mary j blige one of the
greatest r
b singers to ever walk the earth jay-z
one of the greatest rappers to ever live
eddie murphy one of the funniest actors
to ever ever do it do you know what the
white man that lives next door to me
does for a living
he's a [ __ ] dentist
[Applause]
he ain't the best dentist in the world
he ain't going to the dental hall of
fame
he don't get plaques for getting rid of
plaque
he's just a yank yo two out dennis
see the black man got a fly to get
something that the white man could walk
to
that's right baby he said i had to make
miracles happen to get that house
i had to host the oscars to get that
house
and to this day i don't even believe
it's my house
that's why i keep a bag packed right by
the door
just in case the white people that
really own the place
show up one day time to go blackhead
damn i knew this day would come good
thing i'm packed
do you know what a black dentist would
have to do
to move into my neighborhood he'd have
to invent
teeth